the single market is one of Europe's
great achievements it allows products
and services to move freely across the
EU it enables people to live work travel
and study where they wish and ensures
that the products you buy are subject to
the same high safety and environmental
standards wherever they come from and
wherever they are sold but not all of
the opportunities agreed on paper have
become a reality yet and with the world
around us changing innovative ideas and
innovative business models must find
that place too so it's time to give the
single market a boost
time to help professionals who want to
offer their services abroad get their
qualifications recognized more easily
time to allow startups to expand an
innovation to flourish to cut red tape
preventing companies from offering their
services across the EU to give consumers
a bigger market in which to shop for the
best quality and price and make Europe a
more attractive place to invest in
getting it right will create jobs and
growth and give you more choice more
mobility more freedom the EU single
market time for a boost